[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera sono daniele cade un
responsabile nazionale del comparto
ovicaprino della lega delle cooperative
questa sera parliamo di pastorizia
proverò a coniugare la pastorizia sarda
insieme anche ai problemi economici
della nostra regione e alle potenzialità
che la cooperazione in questi ultimi 50
anni è riuscita a dare al settore
parliamo di un settore che inizia a
svilupparsi in maniera forte alla fine
dell'ottocento quando in pratica gli
interessi di alcuni grossi commercianti
degli stati uniti si incrociarono con
quelli di alcuni caseari ed industriali
laziali così da poter utilizzare l'isola
per produrre latte come produzione
appunto di formaggio quasi sempre per
cui non romano che andava appunto a
finire nelle negli stati uniti questi
grossi latifondisti ovviamente facevano
poi l'interesse loro e degli industriali
e questo è rimasto tale fino a quando
poi una legge le cuoca non ha consentito
a questi di disinteressarsi della
produzione sarda di dare i terreni ai
pastori che hanno iniziato la
lavorazione dei terreni la costituzione
dei greggi e la produzione di latte da
per poter poi produrre il prodotto
finito e quindi il formaggio queste
grosse difficoltà iniziali che era
appunto quella dovuta a una produzione
di un prodotto spesso povero che non
veniva remunerato in termini di quantità
importante anche perché gli americani
non si riconoscevano una grande un
grande valore aggiunto al all'allevatore
al pastore stava bene perché attraverso
gli incentivi nazionali e regionali
riusciva poi a far quadrare a far
quadrare i conti
quando poi però si è iniziata ad
affrancare la volontà dell allevatore di
riuscire ad ottenere maggiore
remunerazione da quel prezzo e quindi di
uscire anche dal binomio industriale ed
esportazione sono iniziati a venire
fuori appunto le prime aggregazioni di
di cooperative la cooperativa più
anziana che abbiamo in sardegna è datata
mille
907 è la l'accesa di bortigali
da quel momento inizia un ascesa del
comparto cooperativistico in sardegna
che porterà ad avere in alcuni in alcuni
momenti anche 50 cooperative che
producevano latte ovi caprino
allo stato attuale sono molto meno sono
una trentina con alcuni in grossa
difficoltà altre che sono punte di
eccellenza e che veleggiano ormai tra i
70 ei 60 anni i 60 anni di vita
ovviamente questo per noi è un settore
trainante è importantissimo vale un
terzo dell'economia sarda ed è
importante anche perché in esso abbiamo
speso e risorse abbiamo speso
intelligenze e abbiamo cercato negli
anni anche di migliorare quelle quelle
che erano le difficoltà ma soprattutto è
un settore importante per l'intero
bacino del mediterraneo
pensate che l'intero comparto ovi
caprino mondiale trova nel bacino del
mediterraneo il 20 per cento della sua
produzione
cosa che non avviene invece nel settore
vaccino che rappresenta in questa zona
del mondo solamente il 7 per cento
abbiamo delle produzioni differenti
perché abbiamo una zona del mediterraneo
che più vocata a produrre latte e quindi
ad avere un animale che tende
sostanzialmente a produrre latte per la
trasformazione è un'altra parte invece
che tende sostanzialmente a produrre
agnelli agnelloni da carne come si
possono incontrare questi due momenti
non è sicuramente semplice riuscire a
produrre come dire un un animale che
possa completare la filiera è che possa
essere utile ad entrambe le sponde del
mediterraneo
ma in questi ultimi anni qualcosa
qualcosa si è mosso qualcosa qualcosa è
cambiata ovviamente è cambiata anche
grazie all'apporto diciamo delle
cooperative all'apporto che questa è una
dato anche attraverso rapporti sempre
più stretti con le altre regioni
italiane di produzione vedi la toscana
il lazio e l'umbria ma anche con alcune
parti del
dal nord del nord africa che appunto
producono latte e formaggi ovicaprini
la situazione attuale qual è la
situazione attuale non è più quella di
qualche anno fa e cioè di circa un
milione di ettari vocati alla produzione
di erba e di erbai per per per
consentire alle pecore di di accrescere
il loro valore nutrizionale quindi e
accrescere la proprietà del latte e non
è neanche quella dei 3 milioni di capi
presenti fino a qualche anno fa si sta
cercando di migliorare la qualità
dell'animale e allo stesso tempo anche
attraverso degli studi fatti
dall'università di firenze presentati
anche negli stati uniti quello di far
capire ai consumatori di latte che il
latte di pecora ha delle caratteristiche
superiori al latte vaccino
addirittura anche per contrastare i
tumori alla mammella e al colon con
presenze di proteine all'interno del
latte prodotto in sardegna importanti
proprio per il contrasto a queste due
terribili malattie dovute al fatto che
con una l'ivam un allevamento brado
quindi con una pecora che riesce a
mangiare ea ruminare nel terreno il
terreno sardo è presente sono presenti
alcune proteine che poi vengono ingerite
la dall'animale poi vengono ritrovate
all'interno del prodotto iniziale latte
che poi viene trasferito all'interno del
del prodotto finito
certo diciamo che è una un embrione di
tentativo di far passare il latte di
pecora che in maniera oggettiva come vi
ho spiegato prima delle caratteristiche
più più positive di quello di di vacca
ma mentre noi lo produciamo consumiamo
in misura importante nel nord europa
questo non avviene
e c'è sempre stata una produzione anche
a stabulazione fissa del bovino molto
molto superiore rispetto a quella delle
pecore
ci sono stati poi come la francia
piuttosto che la germania
all olanda che stanno tentando una
conversione la francia soprattutto visto
che produce tantissimo latte e prodotti
caprini ma siamo ancora lontani da
quelle che sono le percentuali
diciamo di produzione del mediterraneo
come possiamo noi a questo punto cercare
di concretizzare la produzione di latte
di formaggio e quindi di farlo fai
quindi farlo diventare un prodotto
adatto ad alto consumo anche nelle altre
regioni italiane ed europee
innanzi tutto ovviamente rafforzando il
sistema cooperativistico facendo capire
all'allevatore che all'interno di un
sistema in cui lui non è solo produttore
ma governa anche quel sistema può dare
un valore aggiunto a questo sistema
stesso e allo stesso tempo lavorando
attraverso gli enti strumentali che
purtroppo negli anni si sono mangiati
parte di quegli incentivi che la regione
lo stato riservava agli allevatori ma
attraverso di questi questa volta
provare invece ad inventare o a trovare
quelle soluzioni per l'accrescimento del
della compagine societaria e quindi del
dei manager che vanno ad affiancare le
cooperative ed egli degli allevatori e
dei produttori stessi non è ovviamente
un impresa facile
se noi pensiamo che oggi in sardegna del
30 cooperative presenti chi ha un
direttore o un responsabile di
stabilimento
possiamo contarli sulla ditta sulle dita
di una mano quindi con percentuali molto
molto più bassa rispetto a quello che
avviene negli stabilimenti ad esempio di
produzione di latte vaccino negli
stabilimenti di produzione di vino e
così via
molto comunque è stato fatto in questi
in questi anni in sardegna ci troviamo
ad avere cooperative che sono passate
nei decenni dalla produzione di qualche
milione di litri di latte alla
produzione di qualche decina di milioni
di litri di latte
questo è stato possibile anche
attraverso il rafforzamento e il
riconoscimento delle organizzazioni dei
produttori
che per essere riconosciute avevano
necessità e bisogno di un tot di numero
di soci e di un tot di litri di latte
lavorate è di un tot di milioni di di
euro di fatturato
questo sistema ha avuto un'accelerata
all'inizio degli anni duemila è una
frenata nella seconda il secondo nella
seconda parte del decennio degli anni
duemila
questo riportato i caseifici a ragionare
in termini singoli non piura non più
aggregati e ha portato anche ad avere
una grossa una grossa problematica
allegata al bilancio e quindi col
rischio della chiusura di quelle aziende
che non si reggevano più sul mercato non
solo per una mancanza di prodotto di
qualità ma anche perché la monocoltura
del pecorino romano portato a queste
aziende a dipendere troppo da quello che
erano le
le risposte del mercato rispetto
rispetto a a questo prodotto
quindi in sintesi che cosa si deve fare
che cosa si può fare per accrescere
ancora di più il valore aggiunto del
prodotto latte latte di pecora e latte e
latte e latte di capra
innanzitutto quello di cercare di
accrescere la capacità di produrre in
termini di qualità alle aziende quello
di contingentare la produzione quello di
avere una scheda per ogni azienda una
scheda di produzione di latte in qualità
che renda oggettiva la pioggia tivo il
conferimento è l'attribuzione al latte
di quel produttore attraverso una
griglia appunto qualità come avviene già
in altri prodotti e come avviene in in
alcune aziende ma soprattutto quello di
cercare di aggregare in tre o quattro
grossi poli del latte in sardegna che a
quel punto realmente possono sfidare
all'interno del comparto ovi caprino
colossi di altre parti del mondo
non parliamo della delle cooperative
delle altre regioni italiane perché ad
esempio il lazio è la seconda regione
per produzione a tre cooperative sono
tre cooperative di conduzione quindi di
pastori che si mettono assieme e che
alla fine d'anno il prodotto degli
industriali per cui il sistema di
trasformazione e commercializzazione in
questo caso è presente è presente solo
in sardegna come organizzazione e mi
permetto di dirlo che cosa stiamo
cercando di portare avanti e di
sensibilizzare innanzitutto la caduta di
alcuni campani e campanilismi e di
alcuni luoghi comuni si tende ancora
oggi in sardegna a dividere il momento
della produzione con quello della
trasformazione e quindi a provare a
giocarsi utilizzo questo termine
l'allevatore come se fosse oggi
dell'associazione agricola domani
dell'associazione copat cooperativistica
non è così l'allevatore è sempre un
allevatore che fa parte
dell'associazione agricola ma quando in
cooperativa e all'interno di un
organismo e di una cooperativa di
trasformazione
bisogna capire che non siamo in grado
attraverso una produzione contingentata
di gestire il prezzo del latte sempre
comunque bisogna capire che il mercato
ha un ruolo fondamentale è che noi non
ne possiamo prescindere
bisogna capire che gli strumenti
pubblici non possono più essere utili a
coprire buchi di bilancio che le imprese
riescono spesso ad avere proprio perché
non controllano questa questa produzione
quindi in sintesi noi riteniamo sia
fondamentale ripeto arrivare a una
produzione sempre più equilibrata ad
avere una difesa di una diversificazione
del prodotto molto più spinta e quindi
non si deve sempre dipendere da quello
che il prezzo del pecorino romano e la
produzione di esso è anche alla crescita
del del gruppo dirigente delle
cooperative e quindi anche degli
allevatori e delle loro aziende
se riusciremo a fare questo riusciremo
anche a utilizzare bene i soldi che sono
messi a disposizione dal piano di
sviluppo rurale 2014 2020
probabilmente riusciremo anche a far
fare un salto di qualità al settore ovi
caprino ma dobbiamo essere anche
consapevoli che se continuiamo con le
guerre interne all'interno della nostra
del nostro territorio
probabilmente non faremo un bene né al
settore né alla sardegna e ci
aspetteranno anni di grossa crisi visto
l'aggressività del mercato non solo del
latte animale ma anche del latte
vegetale e quindi al istintivo consumo
inferiore
di questi prodotti per cui dobbiamo
essere consapevoli e coscienti che non
sono anni semplici quelli che ci
attendono ma dobbiamo essere anche
consapevoli che fino a questo momento
l'unico strumento che ha fatto sì che il
comparto crescesse e si affrancasse è
stato quello dell'aggregazione sia essa
cooperativa in molti casi sia essa
industriali in altri in altri però siamo
siamo sicuri che da lì si deve partire
cercando appunto di mettere assieme
tutte quelle come dire evoluzioni che il
comparto ha avuto in sardegna e tutti
quei punti di forza e anche quei punti
di debolezza che in questi in questo
secolo di vita
abbiamo conosciuto attraverso
l'evoluzione del nostro comparto
[Musica]